Itzik appetites victims feeds on their
babies and gives the decapitated remains
to its own babies to eat and now it's
coming to North America this is
everything you need to know about murder
Hornets in six minutes
ready go dubbed the murder Hornet by the
US media the Asian giant Hornet has a
sting that can be fatal to humans native
to Asia this Hornet was spotted for the
first time in the US this past December
and it's got people worried yeah this is
brand new to me and our department is a
queen from Japan of the Asian giant
we're not entirely positive what the
threat will be we have to take all the
precautions we can Veen mandarina have a
lethal Anatomy it's the largest Hornet
in the world
the female worker Hornets can grow to
about an inch and a half long and their
Queens can grow to two inches in length
their faces are cartoonishly fierce with
large teardrop shaped eyes their orange
and black stripes lead to broad wings
that more so resemble a dragonfly than a
bee these Hornets have large mouths
shaped like a spiked shark fin mouths
that are able to decapitate victims
humans can die from a series of stings
from their long stingers so long in fact
the Hornets stinger can puncture through
a standard beekeeping suit unlike the
honey bee which can only sting once the
Hornet can sing multiple times the sting
has been described as a lot like having
hot metal driven through the skin every
year there are people in Japan that are
hospitalized for multiple stings and
some even died the USDA estimates the
Hornets killed between 30 to 50 people a
year in Japan if you are one of the
people that is unlucky enough to stumble
into a nest and get stung that's a
definitely going to hurt if you're
allergic you could go into shock but
even if you're not allergic the venom of
the Hornet attacks red blood cells and
can lead to kidney failure and death the
human health risks are real the murder
Hornet moniker has created a lot of fear
and hysteria that's probably overblown
the so-called murder Hornets are a big
deal but not because they're going to
murder you
these insects should probably be more
afraid of humans in Japan their nests
are hunted for trophies
the
Hornets themselves are eaten fried or
steamed and even drowned in alcohol and
served and showed you consuming them is
said to elicit a tingly warm sensation
and increase virility the real reason we
should be scared of these giant Hornets
is because of their threat to our
honeybee population through their
pollination honeybees contribute around
15 billion to the US economy per year
and these murder Hornets have the
capability to completely Massacre them
so how does the Asian giant Hornet
attack honeybees first a worker Hornet
targets a honeybee colony placing a
pheromonal mark to signal to the other
Hornets this mark isn't secret the
honeybee sends it to hiding inside their
hive for safety now these Hornets are
uniquely vicious because they attack in
groups they gang up on the colony
quickly decapitating the honeybees and
eating their immature B is growing
inside the bee hives wax cells they take
the remains and feed them to their own
Hornet larvae Japanese honeybees have
actually evolved to develop a mechanism
to fight back if the Asian giant Hornet
arrives alone or in too few numbers it's
the honeybees who come out on top as
many as four hundred bees will surround
it buzzing in a tight ball this action
increases the temperature to nearly a
hundred and fifteen degrees Fahrenheit
and raises the carbon dioxide level
inside the hive a harsh condition that
honey bees can survive but Hornets
cannot unfortunately American honeybees
don't have the ability to create a bee
ball and kill Hornets by frying them in
115 degree heat with no defensive
capability they need our help
the US government along with scientists
and beekeepers are already taking steps
to eradicate the Hornet before it takes
root they're setting up traps to locate
them and prevent further spread and in
the future they may rerelease Hornets
with the radio frequency identification
tags so the Hornet can unknowingly
reveal the location of its colony which
are typically hidden underground in Asia
there are a lot of different ways they
try to stop the Hornets honey bee hives
can be fitted with doors too small for
the Hornets to enter and they might even
resort to using tennis rackets to swap
them we are basing our trapping program
off of things that have been effective
in Japan and Korea where people have
been living with this species for a very
long time
and there are robust public sort of
public survey programs the way we
eradicate them is locating the nest and
then we will send out a team and our
special protective Hornet suits with an
insecticidal dust and kill that
localized nest it's gruesome as that
sounds that's our goal is to is to kill
these off and keep them from
establishing Washington State
hopefully these proactive measures will
stop the Hornet before it takes hold in
the hospitable climate of the Pacific
Northwest and spreads throughout the
rest of the country hopefully we can
save our honeybees which have already
seen a twenty nine to forty five percent
loss in hives
since 2012 bee populations are already
threatened by deadly parasites viral
diseases and exposures to pesticides in
their food and now murder Hornets
I can't they catch a break so if you
hear more about murder Hornets remember
that they're scary to humans because of
their potential to annihilate our bees
not because they're necessarily going to
murder us but on the grand scheme of
risk to human health it's it's low
compared to all the other stuff we do
every day I think if you look at some
mortality statistics falling in your
home is still far more risky and we
don't report murder ladders to them to
the Home Depot so next week unstable and
lethal everything you need to know about
murder ladders in seven minutes